also discussed and exchanged opinions
regarding russian proposals
given to the u.s and nato about giving
long-term security guarantees to russia
and i would like to
say that we
analyze the response given in writing by
the us on 26th of january but
now it's already clear and i
said that to mr prime minister that
russian concerns were basically ignored
we didn't see an
adequate risk adequate response to our
key
concerns non-expansion of nato the
refusal to deploy offensive weapon next
to the russian borders and bringing back
the military infrastructure of the
alliance to the status quo of 1997 when
the
russian nato treaty was signed
and by ignoring our concerns the united
states and nato in general are referring
to the rights of the states to freely
choose ways to ensure one's security